somebody asked me on my twitter they
said hey man gee um you know do i think
little nyx is a is like a tool for of
lgbt i said well really i tweeted but i
didn't add the person i said
little nonsex is not
a puppet for lgbtq if anything he's a
puppet for white supremacy and i said
really more than anything that i'm not
feeling about his art you know i'm
saying he's [ __ ] corny
like it's just corny as [ __ ] is it
executed well yes is there some decent
idea there yes the overall idea of the
whole [ __ ] is just actually lame and
corny he's it's a guy named burt
williams right that was a uh
that was a
a black dude that used to do blackface
he was a super talented actor but he was
doing corny [ __ ] but bro why would you
blackface your [ __ ] and that's what i
feel like he's doing with that culture
it's like you just over the top bro and
i get it but it's like sometimes it's
corny that's what i say about little
knives because you and i had a little uh
conversation about little nazis and the
satan's shoe and all that [ __ ] but but
i saw your tweet about about the uh uh
white
supremacy thing and i was like
i truly believe
now obviously he's a pop
musician me and you and the type of
music that we eat i'm not riding around
in my car listening a little no nobody's
listening to little dogs people are like
yeah like white people
right or like main street people he's a
pop star sure right he makes pop music
but he's a brother and that's the
problem that's fair that's fair when
you're a brother we expect your [ __ ] to
have some soul some depth
he's [ __ ] a cornball and that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] irritating